my guest tonight of course a hilarious
comedian an actor who was stirred in
ratatouille king of queens and the
goldbergs just to name a few things
his latest stand-up special i love
everything he's currently streaming on
netflix
and he's the executive producer of the
hbo documentary series
i'll be gone in the dark please welcome
uh my really good friend
patton oswalt i'm so happy to talk to
you patton
god bless you yeah this is trust me uh
this interview has been
a lifeline for me this has been like
holding concert tickets
i've known about it for a couple of
weeks it's like if i can just get to
tuesday morning and talk to conan
this is no seriously i was i was coming
to the theater today to tape this and i
was thinking oh
great i i'm so starved uh to talk to
funny people and you're one of my
favorite people and i was like i get to
talk to patton today
and so i i think i drove 80 miles an
hour to get to the theater just so we
could have this uh interview
let's make this about you and then more
about me yes how are you doing
how are you doing during isolation are
you handling this all right
and why are you sitting in a lowe's
theater right now
look when the shelter in place order
came down uh you know i
i was i was in an early screening a
black widow uh no spoilers but you know
i'm just i've been in place and uh
you can live on red vines and sprite
people don't understand this but
it's a it's a very intense diet so
you've been saying
that they they shouted kovid quarantine
while the movie was ending and you just
said i'll just stay here
i go yeah well first i thought is this
part is this
the next phase of the marvel movies
where they actually you know add some
kind of outside
threat like oh no it's really real and
you know i'm kind of the last one left
here a lot of us have gone insane
uh there's one other guy but he he's
living under the seats now so it's just
i'm
kind of the spokesman
they said you you will speak for all of
us here at the abandoned theater
i mean i've been handling things okay i
realized the other day
that a lot of times in the morning i
will go sit on my front porch
we have like a front porch swing and
i'll sit out there and read a book
and the same people will go walking by
and i'm
starting to worry that i'm becoming
the weird fixture in the neighborhood
the guy in his robe
and cargo shorts just kind of waving at
people with a book and they
they use me as oh it's well it's 9 a.m
he's out there
like like i'm the weird neighborhood
clock now that they
kind of set things by but i've become a
guy who sits on his front porch and
waves at people right
right yes the thing you as a child or as
a teenager you thought i'll never be
that guy
ever yes dick oh my god i'm the guy
you know who i am i'm the guy in like
the slasher movie at the beginning
who's like that house has a death curse
they're like
oh come on i turned into that guy yes
you're that guy oh you don't want to go
up there
don't go to the old beardsley place it's
a murder house and they're
shut up you know what i'm missing now
a hair and makeup team i am missing a
hair and makeup team
when okay first off your hair they
should take
they should use time lapse photos that
should be the chronicle of this
quarantine is conan's hair
the the ongoing like the bigger and
bigger it gets
when this quarantine ends every actor
and actress we should organize some
massive
dinner celebration parade just for hair
and makeup people they should they
should be
whenever we see them we should like
avert our gaze and kneel like
yes yes they are so clearly
such a crucial they're beyond crucial
in show business i mean we we knew that
they were valuable but my god
the the next whatever the next live
academy award should be
there should be they should like have a
uh they should they bring a powder puff
out on stage
we should all like stand and just kind
of worship it just like
some kind of bee shining thing right oh
my god
hair and makeup people i i've always
tried to be nice to you but i was not
being nice enough i
promise you this is so i almost i'm
going to show up in that
trailer every day with muffins and
coffee
and just thank you i've been uh
frightening people online with my hair
every day on the show
because every day like some days i kind
of comb it up a little bit but it's
gotten so long
jesus there's like nine feet of hair
and then it turns into this tsunami but
then if i let it go it comes down and i
sort of look like
you know hey man i'm just playing my
song man
and i'm pushing my hair back this way
and uh yeah it's
i i but i'm just sort of enjoying
letting it all
go just let it all go yeah if you if you
didn't have any product in your hair
right now
you would look like the one viking on
the raid that like knows
what all the like the codes and codexes
mean like there's the big brownie guys
you're like
no this means there'll be dragons listen
to like you're the guy they bring along
wait a minute so i'm not the good
fighter or the strong
viking i'm the guy that's like i know
the signs
well no they they bring you along to
translate like
so they make sure they don't open any
cursed items that's who they bring a lot
hey um um have you found
what are the positives has this changed
because i i keep looking for silver
linings
has there been anything that's changed
your perspective during this
quarantine where you think okay i didn't
think about that before but
now now my perspective is different uh
maybe the
maybe the internet and twitter and being
online isn't the be
all end all like what if this what if
the quarantine
is is the version of you catch your kid
smoking so you make him
smoke a carton of cigarettes we've all
been online so much
and i almost think when the quarantine
lifts there's going to be a crazy shift
away
and just i just want to be outside
actually looking at people
actually embracing stuff and and the
tactile world
wow what if that's an actual thing
that's going to happen
wouldn't it be a weird backlash against
like all the
being online because of being stuck
inside
i think there will be i think it will
last about four hours
everyone's gonna go outside and touch
trees and breathe air
and touch each other and and go to
restaurants for about four hours and
then everyone's going to go back
to these things yeah and they'll they'll
all do instagram stories about being
outside and not being on
the internet wow yeah and then
well yeah and then on the other hand
uh i've gotten way too into watching way
too many
movies and tea and and it what you
really what you find out very quickly is
all of the really good stuff that's on
netflix and hulu
and canopy and uh shutter and all these
channels
um you go through the good stuff pretty
quickly and then you start
searching for the the weirdest like i'm
actually craving bad film so like i've
been watching
steven seagal movies and if anyone
there's a lot of
later steven seagal movies on netflix
he's the ones that he makes where
he just does not get up out of his chair
in the
if there's any steven segal movies the
later ones on netflix
watch them with closed captioning turn
the subtitles on because these poor
closed captioners
heavy breathing heavier breathing
squeezing
um you know like there's just a lot of
they will articulate
how badly he's doing physically is there
actually a closed captioning that says
aging badly
you know i was thinking about it fresh
from craft service
um you uh you are a victim of this
because
uh you did in your stand-up special i
love
everything someone found this and they
put it out there and i think you've been
spreading it around too
they took a freeze frame of the closed
captioning that accompanied you
on stage and it
says uh rambles comma groans let's take
a look at that right now there it is
this is an actual closed captioning for
you rambo's comma
groans why that
because closed captioners or i know
people that that have worked closed
captioning a lot of them
are struggling writers struggling
performers they've got to try to make
that job interesting
so they will slip in little moments of
poetry whenever they can
and that's a that's a gorgeous moment
rambles comma groans
that will that will be the title of my
next
special that's perfect perfect and it's
so
what this time is right now that is if
there are two words to describe
2020 it's rambles comma groans
you know i was trying to dis and we just
we we start rambling angrily and then we
just sort of pause and then we just kind
of give up and
and the other person isn't offended by
that they're just like yeah exactly
yes yeah awful now speaking of
entertainment i know you're a film buff
and uh and we've established that you
live in a theater now
your daughter alice this seems to me
because this is what i've been doing
with my kids
i've been trying to use this time to say
hey we're all here together
you're going to watch great great movies
with me and they do
and they really like them what have you
been showing your daughter
uh what what kind of stuff you've been
showing her it's been amazing i've been
showing her a lot of the movies that i
grew up on so i showed i've shown her
groundhog day she loved it i showed her
raising arizona which is a surprisingly
good kids movie for like kids 11 and up
there's not really that much cursing and
all the violence is like a
it's like a roadrunner cartoon it's a
it's very cartoony it's a great movie
yeah but then i also showed her the
first matrix film
which um she thought was hilarious and
like
so they go into a computer and they can
do anything and
things just like when i would go see
star wars when i was little and then i
immediately wanted to
fight with the light like i got a broom
handle and fought like a lightsaber
she wanted to do the matrix so she
we have we have a trampoline in the
backyard and she made me
film her in matrix style which i also
have some film of if you want to show
that
yeah yeah we have this and
it's pretty cool because uh she does a
pretty good move in slow motion
yeah she kind of lands a move so if you
want to yeah check that out watch let's
put that up right now
take a look
that is quite impressive and it makes
you wonder why more of the matrix
didn't take place on a child's
trampoline on a child's track exactly
why didn't they use that more and why
didn't they have the thing where
i mean she basically figured out a way
to do
frozen bullet time yeah raises her
bullet in the net
in the net yeah they're spending way too
much money on those films they don't
need
you just need a net and a trampoline
tell me tell me how the movie looks any
better than that movie that i just shot
i mean seriously
i have a good recommendation for people
out there for you too i watched this
uh the other day i had a craving for
kind of a cheesy movie i wanted to kind
of hate watch something
so uh death wish three death wish three
i'm telling you
uh yes uh charles bronson arrives in new
york city
he arrives and it was shot in 1985. he
arrives in a perfectly fine
new york city he shows up at the port
authority everything's functioning fine
he gets in a cab and he goes to a part
of the bronx
where there are dirt roads yes dirt
roads
no law gangs riding around
everything's on fire no one's calling
the cops are like what are you gonna do
we've lost control and i'm like call in
the army for god's sake
it's insanity edgar wright is obsessed
with that movie he i
he he and i talk about the movie all the
time one
yes it was shot in 88 it was shot in
london
there's an the establishment coming to
the port authority they shot that and
the rest of it they went over to london
they barely disguised london as new york
that's why it looks like
this doesn't we it doesn't look like
america
at all um he's flat out
murdering people in the street when he
shoots the giggler and there's every
there's like
20 witnesses watch this guy bait the
dude
shoot him in the back and they'll go
yeah they're all just hearing
a murderer it is an insane movie and
uh i'm i i think if anyone takes
anything away from this
work listen today we're we're not just
mentioning your projects
uh i love uh everything and i'll be gone
in the dark
we are also plugging death wish three
and you know what they shot the giggler
man
oh and the big villain in the movie with
the reverse
like well we already got the punks with
the mohawks and i think people are used
to that
so how do we freaking we'll do a reverse
mohawk
the actor who plays that guy played
chuck on happy days that was
richie cunningham's older brother older
brother who never
appeared again in the show apparently
vanished
went to the bronx and became an insane
mutant criminal
uh you know it's the weird thing about
happy days and i know this is you and i
we can go down these rabbit holes and
not get to anything we're supposed to
talk about
but the crazy thing about happy days is
i think it's it's the it's one of the
sitcoms one of the only ones i can think
of
where they introduce a family in the
first season
and there's an older brother now the
easy thing to do in the second season is
say
yeah he went away you know he's in the
army he's traveling
yeah he's no suddenly they're a fa
they're a family
that never had an older brother and it's
scary it's
scary yeah it was in i wonder how many
people that scarred like with their kids
like
if i misbehave can my family just kind
of vanish me or
disappear me yeah like in in the
pictures like they stalling that dude
out of that
he's just airbrushed out of
everything it's so you know i have to
mention something which is
i am i think about you every day since
we've come to largo
because largo as i've been explaining to
people watching our show largo
is like the comedy theater
in los angeles it's this magical spot
and
we all come here and perform
uh when and the crowds are great and
it's this lovely old theater i got my
start here in 85 in a little room
uh lisa kudrow and i were literally
right across that's where we met
in this small room back in 86 when i
first came to la
and but there are pictures up of
everybody who's performed here
your picture's everywhere here because
this was apparently your second home
yes i've seen you many times i think
this is where you met
your late wife michelle isn't that right
yes i i did a show
um and i talked about uh it was a
yeah it was it was a show um and on
stage i did a bit about um
uh how uh irish women are my kryptonite
and uh and after the show she she was
walking out with some
and she was like hey irish girl is nice
and i was like thank you went just like
stunned and then my friend was greg
barron was like go
talk to her you idiot like he told me to
go talk to her so then i
ran out on the street and my first words
to her were hey
because she was 50 feet away already and
then i was like
i don't i don't have any game or
anything i just you seem really cool
here's my phone number could we go get
dinner like i just was
no i'm not gonna try to be smooth or
cool here i i am hapless with women so i
just
you know and that's how we met uh
this is uh i'm very happy
that you have managed to and and you've
uh worked with other people
pulled together this six-part
docu-series
yeah i'll be gone in the dark which is
such a great
lovely tribute to uh your late wife
michelle
mcnamara's work of of i mean
her obsession with uh with the golden
state killer
and her determination and you've
put this all together and it really is a
remarkable testament
to what she was able to do i mean so
much
of it on her own and with some other
people in the community
who it's such a tribute to people online
who who are determined to solve
something they're not professionally
trained it really is a fantastic story
it's amazing the director liz garvez who
is such a genius um has put together
this narrative that i don't i didn't
know how she was going to do it from
you know taking taking a book that was
already expansive and expanding it out
even further
to go into the victims lives and the
survivors lives and how
resilient they were and then everything
that michelle went through and
did what michelle wanted to do which was
the the
the killer is the least important part
of this story he you know he's just this
insect that's disrupting what should it
should be a thriving ecosystem and then
for what damage he's able to do the
ecosystem ends up thriving even more
and so the fact that she's able to show
all of that
to me is just amazing but it's also it's
for me some of them are a little i've
only there are six episodes
i've only been able to watch four i
don't think i'll be able to watch
five and six you know i had to watch all
the rough cuts and after episode four
which was this past sunday
i had to call liz and go i don't think i
can watch any more of these and i hope
you don't think that i'm being
she goes no no i absolutely understand
how amazed you got this far so
um and by the way her memorial service
took place in the largo i i was here
yeah i remembered uh
the memorial uh to me to to michelle was
here at the largo
and it was really lovely and uh everyone
turned out
and um i'm thinking of i just thought of
it today and i've thought about it often
when i see michelle in the footage for
the documentary
i remember this time when uh
completely by accident i think all of us
were in hawaii at the same time
that's right and uh
we saw it we ran into each other and you
were with michelle
i'm with my wife liza and we decided
let's all get dinner and we had this
lovely dinner and then i started
remember all of us talking to michelle
about
this obsession she had with finding this
killer
and i'm you know it was right in my
wheelhouse
so yeah i remember that spectacular
evening very fondly
you know that that would happen a lot we
would go to dinner with another couple
and
we would start off just kind of all
talking about whatever and then once it
once it got out what michelle does when
she was working on the whole dinner just
became so
but how do you tre you use yeah quest
that is and she's like well yeah
it was always i remember there was a
time i was developing
a sitcom for myself with phil rosenthal
and there was a really telling moment
when he was like
i wanted it to be very very real life
like you know what my life was he goes
what does your wife do and i explained
to him what michelle did
and he said okay well that's a way more
interesting
show than what we're writing so in this
show your wife's going to be a party
planner because
if your wife if your wife in this show
does what michelle does no one's going
to want
like why are we focusing on this idiot
doing i want to focus on her i was like
yeah that's probably a good idea so it
was that kind of thing
um you know one thing that i wanted to
mention uh too
while i well i have you here is you are
so funny uh and and
so sharp tweeting about our president
often
and we're in this moment right now uh
where of course
things have gotten to a level of
insanity it does really feel like
it feels like we're living in death wish
three like
the streets are you know but you are
still seem to have
kind of an optimistic attitude about the
situation we're in right now which is
which fascinates me you and i are big
history buffs you've caught me reading
robert carro's
lbj books and all of you know all of uh
uh reagan land and nixon land and the
invisible bridge and all those
so i try to look to history for comfort
but what i'm also realizing
is trump as bad as he is
uh you know he is the boomers last
temper tantrum before they die
that's what we're looking at every
generation as they get older
and they start to be realized they're
being phased out
the boomers were like we were the
cutting edge we were the
disrupters and now they're seeing no
there's there's
gen x there's millennials there's gen y
there are so so they picked
what's the last thing we can do to have
a tantrum and it was
donald trump the most awful bloated
white dude and as bad as he is i always
tell my gen x friends and i try to tell
millennials or whatever like i'm out
talking to people but like
like as bad as this tantrum is just know
that whatever our gen x tantrum is going
to be even worse when we are
when we are in our 60s and 70s we are
going to have some crazy tantrum
where we know we were the cool ones and
god
knows who we're going to put up there
it's going to be eddie vetter or janine
garofalo and
and i love those two i love janine she's
a friend
but she would agree with me she'd be a
terrible president
she would take the white house and go uh
you know what i'm just not showing up
today i you know i
don't feel good i'm not doing it or
eddie vettel would be like
i'm just doing all the all of the white
house business is going to be done here
on the at the beach i'm just going to be
sitting by my center board
and i shudder to think what our temper
tantrum's going to look like you know i
just love the idea of uh
eddie vetter giving his state of the
union speech
but we can't understand him because he
says it the way he sings
and it's like
i don't know the state of the union the
first thing he'll say is
first off this is all bs okay do we all
understand that
all of this is nonsense we shouldn't
even be here man
and so like it'll just be oh it's gonna
be a bad tantrum
it's going to be bad well i'll make sure
i mention these things i love everything
is available to stream on netflix
uh and you uh do feel free to put on the
uh
closed captioning function and uh i'll
be gone in the dark
uh is fantastic it airs sundays at 10
o'clock p.m
on hbo and it's available to stream
on hbo max and uh
it is a lovely tribute and a fascinating
fascinating story so well told
patton i'm thinking about you i'm here
at largo and uh we're holding down the
fort
i've actually put a mattress in one of
the two small dressing rooms
on the floor you know what i went to the
mattress
yeah and so uh and and there's part of
me that that when things get back to
normal and comedians come back i'm gonna
insist they keep the mattress on the
floor and say that's the conan o'brien
memorial mattress
yeah well you know way high over your
left shoulder there's a pinata shaped
like me
i see it right here there it is oh my
god
yeah there's also a i think i showed
this online but there's a um
she's a beautiful beautiful woman we all
love her
but there's an absolutely horrifying
crocheted pillow
sarah silverman on it which haunts my it
haunts my dreams
it's it's truly haunted i think mark
cohen made that
and uh oh god yeah look at that
it's this is a crime scene it is
yeah sarah we love you and you're
absolutely gorgeous
this i don't think anybody looks good as
a crocheted pillow
no and also a crocheted pillow with
someone's face on it
that's like found in ed gein's house
it says serial killer written all over
it
oh it's amazing a lot of um stuff here
uh
i'm really i think i need to spend a
night here since there's a mattress here
i'm gonna probably sleep here one night
um you know what happens conan at night
all that stuff comes alive
i'm just letting you know you don't want
to spend the night there it's something
else
it all comes to life and they all just
have sex with each other
i was going to say they have a creepy
dance party
to collaborate music and you went right
to they have an orgy
yeah i'm sorry you know sorry sorry
maybe it starts with your vision and
ends with mine all right uh patton uh
i miss you i love you and i hope we see
each other in person soon okay
yes and i'm gonna keep and i'm gonna
keep checking it on your hair
everyone should keep watching conan to
check in on the hair everywhere this
will be an indication of how it's going
in in the america
it really is that is that's how we're
measuring this
yeah this is the new like the richter
scale measures earthquakes this
measures the united states response to
the pandemic
wow that's just that's amazing
um all right i bow to you sir thank you
very much for doing this
get out of that theater man get out of
that theater
all right i'll see you soon take care
okay you too bye